abone ol
Herkese merhaba Hadi vergi nusturucu
Adana Büyükşehir Belediyesi şehir
tiyatroları'nda oyuncu olarak görev
yapmaktayım aynı zamanda kuvvetin aynı
anda evcil
aynı zamanda ana kuzusunun aynı zamanda
Sokak için can atan bir adamım
buraya gel
ne kadar önemsediğimi size göstermek
için berbere gittin
saçıma cırt sürmek istediğim
berber Selçuk
her gün
çeker misin dedi içerim dedim İran'a
döndü dedi ki Ergün abine çay getir
tatil bana da getir dedi
Akçay bir tek bana geldi
Adana'daki Berberler genelde böyle bu
Selçuk amca da onlardan bir tanesi
sırasıyla asmış bir Caprio redrix
Kenan İmirzalıoğlu Kıvanç Tatlıtuğ
oturdu biri koltuğuna Eğer gülüm dedi
hangisi yapayım seni Ben de imrendim
dedim ki Kenan İmirzalıoğlu gibi yap
beni kapıda bir çıktım Hakkı Bulut
enteresan berber bizim Selçuk
oyuncuyum çoğunuz belki tanıyorsunuz
beni
sinemalarda ve dizilerde yer alıyorum
sanıyorum kimse tanımadı
mesela Kurtlar Vadisi Irak dini film var
Belki orada
Kurtlar Vadisi Irak filminin hemen Baş
Çok
teşekkür ederim
Kurtlar Vadisi Irak filminin hemen
başında
izleyenler görmüştür mutlaka beni
Amerikan askerleri mahkumları
çırılçıplak Soyar
sonra mahkumları üst üste atar O
mahkumlardan sekizincisi benim
tanımanızı çok doğal Çünkü orada
çıplaktı mı mı suyu Sam inanın
tanırsınız
bir film çektim Ben filminin galası
yapıldı
iyiyim Bitti tebrikleri aldığım Annem de
istiyor Annemle beraber izliyorum anneme
döndüm Dedim ki anne filmi Nasıl buldun
dedim annem dedi
atlet giydin mi
Affet o kadar önemli bir şey sen de yap
yapıyorum komedinin fakat istenen yap
yapmanın en bu kitaplarından bir tanesi
bu işi yapan bir adamın ünlü olması
lazım bizim adına da gazete imtiyaz
sahipleri var Onlar da benim bir an önce
bu uluslararası alanda ünlü olmamı
istiyorlar bir gazete camiler içi her
gün farklı yerlerde farklı isteyen
tatlar yapmalısın dilim çiğ Ne yapayım
Diriliş Oğlum burası Adana git dedi
kebapçıdan sen ne yap yap
bu fikri Benim önceden neden aklıma
gelmedi gittim Bir kebapçıda Sen ne
yaptın sağ olsun benim için olacak
kurdular onların önlüklerinde Taksim
hissettiğimi Taksim 300 tane adama bir
buçuk saat boyunca 300 tane tüm yaptım
hem durum yaptım hem Sen ne yaptın Sen
ne yapıyorsun ince CNN Türk'ün muhabiri
mikrofonu eline aldı Ergün Bey de değil
çıkan seyirciye sorar mısınız nasıldı
diye haberlerde kullanacağız edit ne
dediğimi çıkana sordum nasıldı dedim
arkadaş biraz soğanlı yapmışsın dedi ya
adamın hakkında sadece kebap kalmış
sonra bir gazete imtiyaz sahibinin iki
her gün
karanlıkta sen ne yap yap Evet dediğim
ya karanlıkta Sen daha bu benim önce
neden aklıma gelmedi eski Yunan ve Roma
tragedyaları karanlıkta oynanırdı gittim
Doğal Park amfi tiyatroda atıyor bu
ışıkları kapattırdım karanlıkta Semra
Yalnız ben karanlıkta Sen de öp yaparken
salondan öpücük sesleri
inleme sesleri
[Müzik]
Mustafa ağabey ışıkları yakışıklı yaktım
Bir baktım Herkes koşa kuşağa
kullanmışlar beni
o yüzden ünlü olamadım zaten adına da
Ünlü olsan ne olur ki adına düğünü
olduğu zaman arama yüze ne diyorlar
karşıdan karşıya geçerken İtimat dolmuş
üzerinde
abi seni tanıyorum diyor ulan
öldürüyordum ya da küfür ediyorlar
çok garip adına da ünlü olmak karşıda
beni görüyor öldürür senin onun Bulut
lan Neden ben böyle ünlü olmak
istemiyorum sen ne yap yapmak sahnede
olmak Hakikaten çok güzel bir şey ünlü
olmak ünlü olmak bu kadar dönemli mi
Uğur İzgi vermesine şehir
tiyatroları'nda ünlü bir adam biz Bunlar
Ramazan etkinliğine gittik Ceyhan e
Ramazan etkinliği bittikten sonra bir
yerde çorba içiyoruz herkes Oğuz diye
bakıyor Yahu sonra gittiler dediler ki
Uğur Bey Uğur veya sizi tanıyoruz Bizler
nereden tanıyoruz uğurda bir artist ya
Sinemalardan ya da dizilerden olabilir
mi oy Verdiğinizi herkes Urla fotoğraf
çektirdi biz böyle bak sıkora aynı şey
benim başıma da geldi
stadyum Caddesi'nde yürüyordum arkamdan
çocuğun biri koşarak geldi
Amin abi ben seni tanıyorum dedi
da sinemadan ya da diziden olabilir mi
dedim yok dedi Sen Hatice ablanın oğlu
değil misin dedi
ya bu kadar tanınmak bu Kader
sen de yap Evet
komedyenlik tiyatro Evet ama sen defıne
handikap larından bir tanesi
seyirci sana gülmez Sen ne yaparsın bu
benim başıma geldi
Gaziantep'te 500 kişilik salon dolu en
örneği protokol Sayın Vali belediye
başkanları meclis üyeleri hepsi var 35
dakika boyunca anlattım anlattım kimse
gülmedi 35. dakika Sayın Vali güldü
Sayın Vali Gülünce Sayın Vali dedim ki
Sayın valim Çok teşekkür ederim Siz
Gülünce herkes güldürelim Sayın Vali
bana ne dedi Seninle bir ilgisi yok
aklıma bir şey geldi ona götürün dedi
bu
zor yaptığımız hiç gerçekten çok zor
bir yani aslına bakarsanız Türkiye stand
up yapmak çok kolay Sadece gazetelerin
üçüncü sayfasını açıp okusanız yeterli
bu aynı zamanda sokak hayvanlarını
koruma ve besleme Kulübü müziğim
sokaktaki Hayvanları çok seviyorum
Gündoğdu Vakfı ile beraber yapmış
olduğumuz bir çalışma vardı Geçen hafta
sona erdi adına da kaç tane Sokak
hayvanı var
Herkese mikrofon uzattık Herkes çok dedi
Çok dedi Çok dediği inanın çok değil
Adana'da iki buçuk milyon 3 milyon insan
var var adına da ilçelerle beraber
sadece
80.000 köpek var 500 bine yakın kedi var
demek ki çok değil
var ama
biz kedileri ve köpekleri gördüğünüz
zaman bir yerde ama ne kadar çoklar
Falan diyoruz ama o kadar çok değiller
Ben de kedi köpek Daha doğrusu Sokak
hayvanı Sevdası çocukluktan başlar bizim
bijon diye bir köpeğimiz vardı kurt
köpeği miz Ben Gözümü açtığım zaman bir
onun beni yaladığını gördüm Benim ilk
lafım anne baba değildi bir şey oldu
önce bir şunu öğrendim ben biz babamla
rahmetli babamla çok severdik Biz
yürürdük yavru kedi gördük Eve getirdik
babam onu yıkardı Kurular Dayı sonra
Papyon takar da ona anneme derdi ki bu
kedi Artık bizimle beraber kalacak sabah
babamla işe giderdik akşam gelirdi Kedi
yok anne kedilerde kedi kapıya çık
bulduk açtı derdi biz yine akşam eve
dönerken Bu kez yavru köpek gördük yavru
köpüğü aldık Ama babam onu yıkadık
uyguladığı Papyon taksi bu Artık bizimle
beraber dedi sabah çıktık gittik akşam
tekrar geldik köpek yok anne köpek
nerede kapı açıktı kaçtı
Biz babamla pazar günü balık avlamaya
gittik Su kaplumbağası bulduk Su
kaplumbağası Babam eve getirdim Niye sen
yıkadık kurguladığı Papyon takmaya
çalıştığı
Su kaplumbağasının leğene koyduk
sabah işe gittik akşam geldik Su
kaplumbağası yok
anne dediğim Su kaplumbağası nerede
kapıyı açık bulduk açtı dedi
o Ulan bu Su kaplumbağasının Buradan
çıkıp oraya gitmesi üç yıl ama biz
mutlaka yolda olmadı yerde Karşılaşırdık
Adanalı hayvan Severdim ya
rahmetli babam derdi ki Atatürk
Parkı'nda bıldırcın Sevenler Derneği
vardı biz oraya giderdik verdi ama
derdim bıldırcınları çok Buse verdiniz
parmağımızı bile yerdeki oğlum dedi ne
orada bıldırcın yiyorlarmış
ben o zaman Sevenler Derneği niye
koyuyorsunuz
Ben kedi ve istiyorum herkese
kelimesini tavsiye ederim evdeki tane
kedim var Evde kedi olduğu zaman evinize
misafir gelmiyor
O çok rahatsız sizin evde kimse yemek
yemiyor
paraları cepte
kediler hayat kurtarıyor ya ve bir de
kedi halleri var kedi besleyen var mı
İçinizde bir el kaldırabilir mi acaba
evindeki düğmesi utanmaya kek Kedi
besliyorsanız kaç Kediniz var bu 47 sizi
hiç gelinmez Siz işi garantiye
almışsınız Biz kapıya yazın girmeyin
diye ne kadar güzel 4 kedi bende iki
tane var ya kedi halleri vardı isminiz
nedir
Gülen güle hanım siz de bazen kedilerden
korkar mısınız şu anlamda Tatar anlık
tam yapmak üzeresiniz kendini söyle
yapar
o Korkmuyor musunuz
onlar ruhları falan görüyorlar mış mış
oğlum Kim var lan orada kapatma
ha Tolga
ile çok güzel yerdir Ya şimdi ben sokak
hayvanları çok seviyorum Daha doğrusu
Hayvanları çok seviyorum empati yaptım
son zamanlarda
tabii şimdi biraz abarttığımı düşünüyor
ama bence hiç kapatmadım Ben bir sokak
hayvanım dedim sokağa çıktım iki gün eve
gelmedin
onlarla beraber yedim
onlarla beraber içtim çöp karıştırdım
Ece savaşına girdim ayak yedim
Şimdi hanım hala baktığımı düşünüyorlar
ne var hala Kaptan yemek yiyorum ne var
yani şuraya koyuyorum oradan ben yerim
diyorum yalnız Bazen abarttığımı
düşünüyorum mesela 2 Az önce Dünya
Kadınlar gününde empati yaptım benim
kadınım dedim
Ulan hala peşinden gelen adamlar varmış
arkadaşım Tamam ise yerleştirdim ama o
kadar da değil
teşekkür ederim beni dinlediğiniz için
izlediğiniz için
Ya tabi sanat eyvallah Sen sizden daha
bir dakika 7 6 5 4 3
2 tam var Zoom bir dakika da şunu
söylemek istiyorum
seversiniz sevmezsiniz
ben saygı duyarım hiçbir zaman da kavga
etmeyin ve etmemde ama sevmiyorsanız be
sizin için söylemiyorum tabii bu lütfen
sokakta gördüğünüz
canlıyız Onun da sizin gibi
ama tarafından yaratıldığını ben onunla
bu dünyada yaşamaya Hakkı olduğunu
lütfen düşünerek sevmesenizde
ihmal atmayın
Yani
bilmiyorum Nasıl bir vicdan var o
insanlar da dediğim gibi kavga etmem ama
lütfen sizden ricam
sokaktaki canlıları bi En azından onlar
için süreye Bakıyorum bu süre slogan en
son iki saniye kala söyleyeceğim lütfen
seven
bir kap Sony kapama Teşekkür ederim ima